.
I'VE BEEN WONDERING FOR FOR
OVER 40 YEARS NOW, LATE
1970S I WROTE MY FIRST
LETTER TO THE EDITOR, I WAS
ROLLING NEWSPAPERS IN A GAS
STATION ONE MORNING ABOUT TO
BEGIN MY PAPER ROUTE.
AND THERE WAS A STORY IN MY
LOCAL PAPER ABOUT U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
IN THAT STORY SOME MEMBERS
WERE REFERRED TO AS
ULTRACONSERVATIVE.
BUT NO MEMBER WAS REFERRED
TO AS ULTRA LIBERAL.
IT SEEMED THEN AND NOW THAT
THE EXTREMISTS ACCORDING TO
THE POLITICAL WRITERS COULD
ONLY BE WITH THE RIGHT, THIS
WEEK I READ STORIES OUT OF
ITALY WITH GREAT INTEREST
THEIR NEW LEADER, MALONE WAS
CALLED FAR RIGHT AND HARD
RIGHT.
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE THIS
WEEK.
OF COURSE, SHE WAS THE FIRST
WOMAN
CHOSEN TO LEAD ITALY, BY
THAT WAS BURIED, IT IS ONLY
HISTORIC IF THE OTHER SIDE
DOES IT THE MEDIA REALLY
WANTED YOU TO KNOW IS SHE
WAS QUOTE, HARD RIGHT OR
QUOTE FAR RIGHT, THAT HAS ME
WONDERING WHO GETS TO DECIDE
WHAT IS LEFT, RIGHT OR
CENTER?
TO SAY SOMEONE IS HARD OR
FAR RIGHT, MEANS YOU KNOW
WHERE RIGHT IS.
AND TO KNOW WHERE RIGHT
S YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHERE THE
CENTER.
IS SO WHO GETS TO DECIDE
THAT?
TO MANY KAMALA HARRIS WAS A
FAR OR HARD LEFT SENATOR.
BUT NOT ACCORDING TO THE
MEDIA, THEY NEVER REFERRED
TO HER THAT WAY.
THE MEDIA TRIED TO CONVINCE
US THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
A MODERATE.
COMPARED TO WHAT?
COMPARED TO WHOM?
THE MEDIA ALSO TOLD US AMY
CONEY BARRETT WAS A DEVOUT
CATHOLIC IN A BAD WAY AND
JOE BIDEN AND NANCY PELOSI
WERE DEVOUT CATHOLICS BUT IN
A GOOD WAY, SAYS WHO?
ACCORDING TO WHAT MEASURE
AM.
TREY: POLITICAL WRITERS?
IS THAT WHO WE LOOK TO FOR
DEFINITION WAS LEFT, RIGHT,
CENTER AND DEVOUT?
WHEN YOU READ SOMEONE IS FAR
RIGHT, OR HARD RIGHT, MAYBE
THEY ARE.
BUT TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TO
KNOW WHERE THE CENTER IS.
WHO GETS TO DEFINE THAT?
IF I CANDIDATE OR ELECTED
OFFICIAL IS FAR RIGHT, WHY
ARE LIBERAL POLITICIANS
NEVER DESCRIBED AS FAR LEFT?
IF YOU WIN AN ELECTION IN A
COUNTRY THAT TELLS ME YOU
MUST HOLD A MAJORITY OR
SOLID PLURALITY OF SUPPORT,
IF A COUNTRY SUPPORTS YOU
CAN YOU BE HARD RIGHT?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS THAT YOU
ARE PRETTY SQUARELY IN THE
MIDDLE OF AT LEAST
WHAT THAT COUNTRY WANTS YOU
TO BE, "NEW YORK TIMES"
DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE WHAT
CONSERVATISM IS OR
CONSERVATIVE BELIEVE OR WHY.
TO THEM EVERYTHING ON THE
RIGHT IS FAR RIGHT.
AND IF THEY THINK THAT JOE
BIDEN IS A
MODERATE, THEY HAVE NO CLUE
WHERE THE CENTER IS EITHER.
IT HAS BEEN 40-SOMETHING
YEARS SINCE I SAT ROLLING
NEWSPAPERS WONDERING WHY
THERE WERE
ULTRACONSERVATIVE JUDGES ON
THE BENCH BUT NOT ULTRA
LIBERAL ONES.
ONLY WE CAN BE FAR OR HARD.
NEVER LEFT.
MY GUESS IS THAT WE DON'T
NEED A FAR LEFT ULTRA
LIBERAL NEWSPAPER OR
COMMENTATOR OR REPORTER
TELLING US WHAT THE CENTER
OF THE COUNTRY.
IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
SEEN THE CENTER OF THIS
COUNTRY, SINCE I WAS A KID
SITTING AT THE GAS STATION.
>> JOINING US NOW IS HOOVER
INSTITUTE SENIOR FELLOW
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US, WHY IS
THERE NEVER A HARD LEFT?
>> YOU HAVE TO START WITH
PREMISE THAT THE LEFT ARE
FEEL -- USING GOVERNMENT
OF POWER TO MAKE EVERYONE
EQUAL.
THEY ALSO REALIZE IT IS COP
RARES TO HUMAN NATURE.
COMMON SENSE.
WE QUIRES A DEGREE OF FORCE
TO FORCE PEOPLE THAT COP
CONTRARY TO OUR
CONTUSION, THEY DON'T JUST
TRUST DEMOCRACY OR 51% OR
THEIR IDEAS ARE GOING TO WIN
51%.
SO WHAT THEY DO IS THEY GO
TO INSTITUTIONS.
AND ON SET OF GLOBAL ZIG,
BIGGEST MONEY IN AMERICA FOR
LAST 30 YEARS HAS BEEN ON
THE LEFT.
AND THEY HAVE SYSTEMATICALLY
ADDED TO THEIR CONTROL OF
THE NEW YORK TIME, CHICAGO,
TRIBUNE AND "L.A. TIMES" IN
THEY CONTROL SOCIAL MEDIA
NOW.
IN A CONTROL HOLLYWOOD, THEY
CONTROL K-12 AND ACADEMIA,
THEY CONTROL WALL STREET IN
THE CORPORATE BOARDROOM THEY
FEEL THEY DON'T HAVE
MAJORITY OF SUPPORT AMONG
THE POPULATION, THEIR
MESSAGE REPELS PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE SEEP WHAT HAPPENS
IN HISTORY FROM FRENCH
REVOLUTION.
WHEN YOU TRY TO FORCE PEOPLE
TO BE EQUAL, YOU USE
GOVERNMENT TO DO IT THEY
HAVE CONFIDENT THEY CAN
CHANGE THE LANGUAGE AND THEY
CAN ADVERTISE AND THEY CAN
MESSAGE AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND USE
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TO GET
THAT MESSAGE ACROSS, THEY
WILL BE ENLIGHTENED,
DISINTERESTED.
AND PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN
HUMAN NATURE WILL ALWAYSING
SELFISH AND RIGHT WING, THIS
IS HOW IT IS, REPUBLICANS
USELY LIVE AND LET LIVE.
THEY HAVE CONFIDENT IN
PEOPLE LIKE US THEY ARE
COMMON SENSE THEN THEY COME
AROUND.
SOME REPUBLICANS FEEL YOU
KNOW WE WOULD RATHER LOSE
NOBLEY THAN WIN UGLY.
THAT THEY HAVE AN EYE THEY
ARE INTENT, DEEP DOWN THEY
DON'T HAVE CONFIDENT IN
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT OR
DEMOCRACY THAT WOULD REFLECT
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE,
THEIR MESSAGE IS NOT APPEAL
TO 51% OF THE PEOPLE.
TREY: YOU KNOW, PROFESSOR, I
GOT A LOT OF CHALLENGES THAT
INCLUDE DIRECT.
I STRUGGLE WITH LEFT AND
RIGHT.
I KNOW THAT IF I TONY KNOW
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
CENTER IS, I WOULD NOT CLUE
WHERE LEFT AND RIGHT WOULD
BE WHO DECIDES ON WHERE THE
CENTER IS?
TO KNOW WHERE LEFT AND RIGHT
IS, YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHERE
CENTER IS.
IS THAT THE SAME --
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
ABSOLUTE VALUE, THERE IS A
CENTER.
THAT IS CENTER ON
THE CONSTITUTION AS WE KNOW
IT AND HANDED DOWN, THAT IS
THE CENTER, THOSE ON THE
RIGHT WHO WANT TO CHANGE IS
MAKE IT ARE THOSE ON THE
LEFT, WE KNOW WHAT
THE CENTER IS.
BUT THEY ARE NOT
ABSOLUTISTS, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE, YOU HAVE SEEN THEM
MOVE, NOW IT IS NORMAL IS
GETTING RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, WHY DO WE HAVE TWO
SENATORS IN EACH STATE WHEN
THEY REPRESENT SMALL POP
POPULATION OR WHY
DON'T WE GET RID OF
FILIBUSTER AND BRING IN TWO
STATES AND PACK THE COURT
OF, ON ANY GIVEN DAY IT IS
ALL RELATIVE IT IS ALL ABOUT
POWER, THEY WANT THEY CAN'T
APPEAL TO PEOPLE ON U.S.
ISSUES, WE GET THESE CYCLE
DRAMAS WITH JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION THEN THE WALLS
ARE CLOSING IN TRUMP RAID,
THEN THE BOMBSHELL PHANTOM
OF OPERA BIDEN SPEECH THEN
SPLICE THEM WITH JUSSIE
SMOLLETT OR VOLLEYBALL,
ANYTHING RIGHT DOWN THE
CENTER, LOOK AT CONSTITUTION
AND DISCUSS ISSUES THEY
DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THAT PROCESS.
WHO IN THE WORLD BELIEVES AN
OPEN BORDER WILL WORK.
WHO BELIEVES 8% INFLATION IS
NOT INFLATION?
WHO BELIEVES YOU SHOULD YOU
KNOW, OBSESS ON RACE AFTER
THIS HISTORY WE HAVE IN
PROGRESS WE MADE, WHO
BELIEVES YOU WOULD SHUT DOWN
FOSSIL FUEL ENERGY, INDUSTRY
WHEN WE WERE THE BIGGEST
NATURAL GAS AND OIL PRODUCER
IN THE WORLD, WITH ALL OF
THE BENEFITS THAT ACCRUED
FROM IT THEY HAVE AN AGENDA
THEY KNOW IS NOT POPULAR
UNLESS THEY DISTRACTION
PEOPLE AND ONE OF THE
REASONS THEY TO IT, IS
LANGUAGE.
THEY DON'T WANT THE CENTER,
THE CENTER WOULD ALLOW FREE
DEBATE ON BOTH SIDES, THEY
THE TO MOVE IT WAY TO THE
LEFT.
>> VICTOR DAVIS HANSON THANK
YOU SO MUCH, WHEN I HAVE YOU
BACK WE CAN TALK ABOUT
RELATIVE IMPLEMENT THAT IS
THE DEATH OF THIS EXPERIMENT
IN SELF GOVERNANCE THANK YOU
FOR JOINING